今日は外れ社長です相手で誕生日を迎えてね14歳になりました
8皆さん本当にありがとうございました鍛造るの日はですねアナとカラオケ行って
メテオきてもう反してプラトゥーしてる気をして終わりました
あと編集までというです何なにげない日常だったんですけども
すごい今が楽しいなって思いましたんだこんな恥ずかしい事を言いたくないジェルです
ねとプレゼントを練っていただきましたねあの
言いたいことが一つあるよ2月14分晴れの皆さんがあると思うんですけどもあの
単なるプレゼント矩行
超になりがちなんですよちょっといいですよありがとうござい
ていいんですよありがとうございます理解写ったいんですよ誕生日プレゼント
チョコレート
良いと思います良いと思いますさんじゅりプレゼントチョコれるするんだいいと思うん
ですけども
ああああバレンタインででもあるからさあまあそれチョコレート私といけば間違いない
と思うんですけども
いやありがたいですよねほんとあげたいんですけども本当ちかというとねチョコ渡して
おけばいいでしょうみたいなことになってしまうんですよアレンたいんだが誕生日だと
その中で
by なんと私が所属している事務所運営さん韓国プレゼント頂きました
そろそ
絶対あブラックサンダーだねあー nude black さんですね
まあ右腕はいいよこれンター
満タンでやっぱ香港と日本の空芸がタン塩行なっ
ですよバレンタインのこれを分娩が完全になってると思うよ大事なのは
ここからだこっちでございますよジャンル空いてるんですけどまだ国会中身見れません
よもういい切るだけどになったんですよ
もう輝進んだまで来ていや待ってようーむだぞまずやもうチョコれた送られてきている
このチョコレートという選択肢はないわけですよその中で果たしてうんうんさんは奥に
何をプレゼントしてくれるのかもう純粋にハードルが高いですよ
純正にハードルが高いのでちょっと
ととってますて上ザベスねあの去年の誕生日とかねサンダルに god 始めて帰って
いるサンダルとか送っていただいてすごくて役だったんですよ
ちょっと期待な意味も込めですとってますよじゃあいますねえ壊れたんだかなんだなん
だろ全然2 p なる
大手紙おっとこれはこれはまだちょっとを読めないぞ手紙とこれ優良カードではないな
手紙2枚一つ何かが入ってました手紙から失礼します
とか爪さんお誕生日おめでた言わない方がいいですね
僕ぞ
[音楽]
深いありがとうございます
深い言葉が書いてありました1900詰めます
を happy birthday
こちらはぐーっと潜っ
何
ちょっと重要な国家が書いてあるぞねいやーほんとこいつもありがとうございます本当
に誰もとなるほど
をちょっとフラゲが大体の予想はついたんですけどまだ読めないとしてまず
ちょっという色っぽいんだなんだかわかんないよなんでわかんないんですよ
動画たねちょっと乳業感が出てましたねちょっと開けさせていただきます
開けますよ開夢の扉ん
普通になり
で何何何相撲バード見てないまだ見てないよ何ですか
何何何いないか服まで入ってるダンスおりますあとこれも
何何軍ぽいああこれはいい
なんか泣けますよ3節からいるよせーのはい
こちら
うわぁ前半ってこれやばいやつじゃない待ったカット待ったこれ多分やばいだったら
動き
会話ですねそしてここには青眼の白龍抜け毛でもふたぁずあじやぱんばテーション
コンパニオン違うアジア米ない食ってるし分待って貼って
これたぶんやばいやつたこれためにヤバイ奴だ値段調べてこれちょっと値段調べてくる
なんか手が震えてきたやばいなあっていう想像を打っては打ってもないぞこれ
いやのプレゼントって値段とかそういうのじゃないんですよここなんですけど
切り鍋じゃないですかああおったったったーお値段
わー
ジャメうわうわうわうわぁ
一般に売ってるんですけどもとあるサイトで見たところこちらのプレイマット販売価格
が
一番3400円でございます
jan
いや極めて高いですよ本当にまずですか
解除これさぁきれないなぁと所記念とってかかっておきます目的ブルーデッキを作っ
てるんではこれは正直めちゃくちゃ嬉しいええすごいなぁ実はですねあの僕ナイマン
マネージャーさんの方がですね遊戯を決行してまして
aa そこら辺の話も通る方でしてあの角ではな時とこの
点数を出せなかった誕生日プレゼントだと思います本当にありがとうございます
うーんはいと言うけすごいなかった指で24歳も授業を楽しみつつ
don omar 揺るぐジャズにはばったりてくるね皆さんまたよろしくお願いし
ます
パンティー
me
[音楽]
あっはぁ